let's just bring you some breaking news  now and surge testing is to be deployed  in tower hamlets  in east london nhs tests and traits is  providing additional testing and genomic  sequencing in targeted areas  within the e1 postcode starting from  tomorrow  which follows the identification of  several confirmed cases of the variant  first identified  in south africa and the variant first  identified in brazil  now all the confirmed cases are  self-isolating  there are no links between these cases  and the cluster of cases recently  identified  in the south london area and everybody  aged 11 years  and over who resides works or is  educated in these postcodes  is strongly encouraged to take a covet  19 pcr test  when invited whether or not they are  showing  symptoms that's a breaking news in this  afternoon